♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE PRESIDENT IS RALLYING
SUPPORTERS IN HERSHEY,
PENNSYLVANIA.
WE WILL HAVE A HIGHLIGHTS AND
NEWSWORTHY MOMENTS FROM HIS
SPEECH JUST AHEAD, BUT FIRST
TONIGHT AT 11:59 A.M. ON JANUARY
TONIGHT AT 11:59 A.M. ON JANUAR2
TONIGHT AT 11:59 A.M. ON JANUAR,
TONIGHT AT 11:59 A.M. ON JANUAR1
TONIGHT AT 11:59 A.M. ON JANUARD
TONIGHT AT 11:59 A.M. ON JANUARN
TONIGHT AT 11:59 A.M. ON JANUARR
TONIGHT AT 11:59 A.M. ON JANUARM
TONIGHT AT 11:59 A.M. ON JANUARP
TOOK THE OATH OF OFFICE TO
BECOME THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, LIKE 12:05 THAT
SOMEDAY DEMOCRATS WERE CALLING
FOR HIS IMPEACHMENT.
THAT IS BARELY AN EXAGGERATION
IF AT ALL, LITERALLY FOR YEARS
THE LEFT HOW TO LINK THE TRUMP
MUST BE MOVED -- REMOVED WITHOUT
THE CONSENT OF VOTERS.
EVERY DAY.
FINALLY, TODAY, THIS DAY THROUGH
THE 11 MONTHS BEFORE THE NEXT
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, THEY
EXPLAIN PRECISELY HOW THEY PLAN
TO DO THAT.
THOSE DEMOCRATS DESCRIBED THEIR
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT TODAY.
WATCH.
>> THE FIRST ARTICLE IS FOR
ABUSE OF POWER.
IT IS AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO EXERCISE THE
POWERS OF HIS PUBLIC OFFICE TO
OBTAIN AN IMPROPER PERSONAL
BENEFIT.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID WHEN HE
SOLICITED AND PRESSURED UKRAINE
TO INTERFERE IN OUR 2028
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THIS GIVES RISE TO THE SECOND
ARTICLE OF IMPEACHMENT FOR
OBSTRUCTION OF CONGRESS.
WE MUST BE CLEAR.
NO ONE, NOT EVEN THE PRESIDENT,
IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> Tucker: GOT THAT.
NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
EXPLAIN THAT VERY SAME PEOPLE
WHO SPENT ALL DAY MAKING EXCUSES
FOR THE LEGITIMATE GOVERNMENT
SPYING ON AMERICAN CITIZENS.
BUT NEVER MIND.
LITERALLY, NO ONE IS ABOVE THE
LAW.
WATCH.
>> NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW, NOT
EVEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> NOBODY IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> NOBODY IS ABOVE THE LAW, NOT
EVEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LEFT.
NO ONE IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> NO PERSON IS ABOVE THE LAW.
>> NOBODY SHOULD BE ABOVE THE
LAW.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: APP, IT IS PRETTY
SIMPLE.
YOU DON'T NEED A LAW DEGREE TO
UNDERSTAND IT.
NOBODY IS ABOVE THE LAW, NOBODY.
EXCEPT FOR MORE THAN 20 MILLION
ILLEGAL ALIENS WHO WHO TELL US
THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO BE HERE
IGNORING OUR LAWS AND SHUT UP,
RACIST IF YOU DISAGREE AND THE
SO-CALLED HOMELESS SHOOTING UP
AND AND LIVING FULL-TIME ON THE
SIDEWALKS.
THE LAW DOES NOT APPLY TO THEM
OR TO SUBWAY JUMPERS AND THE YOU
ORC OR 200 BIDEN.
BUT OTHER THAN THAT, ABSOLUTELY
NOBODY IS ABOVE THE LAW, MEANING
TRUMP.
AND THAT IS WHY THEY ARE
IMPEACHING HIM.
BUT THEY ARE NOT CELEBRATING BUT
THAT FACT.
YOU MIGHT THINK THEY ARE EXCITED
BUT THEY AREN'T.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO BE COMPLETELY
CLEAR ON THIS QUESTION.
THEY ARE EXTREMELY TROUBLED THAT
IT HAS COME TO THIS.
IT IS A SAD DAY IN WASHINGTON, A
MOMENT OF POIGNANT REFLECTION, A
MOMENT RIDDLED WITH SADNESS.
JERRY NADLER, NANCY PELOSI AND
OTHER PEOPLE WHO DID NOT HAVE AN
AUTHENTIC IMPULSE IN THEIR LIFE,
THEY WANT YOU TO KNOW WHAT IS
THE WORD FOR SOLEMN ABOUT WHAT
IS HAPPENING, SERIOUSLY, SOLEMN.
>> GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE.
ON THIS SOLEMN DAY, I RECALLED
THAT THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS
FOR MEMBERS OF CONGRESS IS THE
SOLEMN ACT TO TAKE AN OATH TO
PROTECT AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> THAT IS WHY WE MUST TAKE THIS
SOLEMN STEP TODAY.
THE PRESIDENT'S OATH OF OFFICE
APPEARS TO MEAN VERY LITTLE TO
HIM, BUT THE ARTICLES PUT
FORWARD TODAY WILL GIVE US A
CHANCE TO SHOW THAT WE WILL
DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION AND THAT
OUR OATH MEANS SOMETHING TO US.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
AND IF THAT WASN'T ENTERTAINING
ENOUGH, AND IT WAS, BUT THERE
WAS STILL MORE.
BECAUSE THIS IS WASHINGTON AND
THERE ARE STILL MORE.
>> DIG YOUR HAND DEEPER PRINCESS
TALKING.
TODAY WAS TRUCK DOMINIC
CHUCK SCHUMER WHO FOR A LIVING,
GOES ON THE SENATE FLOOR AND
ACCUSES THIS NETWORK, AND BRACE
YOURSELF FOR HOT AND ACCUSING
FOX NEWS OF BEING DISHONEST, FOR
REAL, WATCH.
>> THE PRESIDENT PUNCHERS
FICTIONS AND BASELESS CONSPIRACY
THEORIES TOLD BY NONLAWYERS ON
FOX NEWS OR SOMEWHERE ELSE.
HERE IN THE SENATE, CERTAIN
MEMBERS OF THE GRAND, OLD PARTY
ARE CONSPIRING WITH ANY CRAZY
CONSPIRACY WHETHER LAUNCHED BY
VLADIMIR PUTIN OR SOME WILD EYED
CRAZY CONSPIRACY THEORIST WHO
MANAGES COME OF COURSE ALL THE
TIME TO GET ON FOX NEWS AND HAVE
HIS STORY OR HER STORY REPEATED.
>> Tucker: IT IS JUST SUCH A
SHAME THAT SIGMUND FREUD: OUT OF
FAVOR AND ATTACKING HIM ON THE
COLLEGE CAMPUSES OF SEXIST.
WE NEED SIGMUND FREUD BECAUSE
IT'S HARD TO RECOGNIZE WHAT'S
GOING ON.
BUT STILL, WRITE THIS DOWN AND
PUT ON YOUR FRIDGE, THE BEST I
AM POLITICS EVER, WHAT THE LEFT
ACCUSES YOU OF DOING IS
PRECISELY WHAT THEY ARE DOING
THEMSELVES.
THEY ACCUSE YOU OF FOSTERING
RACISM.
PUSHING CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
LYING TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
[LAUGHTER]
HARD TO FINISH THE SENTENCE COME
UP COURSE, THOSE ARE THE THREE
MAIN THINGS THEY ARE DOING.
AND PROVES THE POINT ONCE MORE,
THE FIRST ARTICLE OF IMPEACHMENT
ACCUSES THE PRESIDENT OF ABUSE
OF POWER "FOR SOLICITING THE
INTERFERENCE OF FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT, UKRAINE AND THE 2020
UNITED STATES PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION."
SO YOU UNDERSTAND HOUSE
DEMOCRATS ARE ARGUING HERE, THAT
THERE WAS NO MEDDLING IN
AMERICAN POLITICS WHEN YOU WERE
CARRYING THE ENERGY COMPANY
HAIRED OTHERWISE UNEMPLOYED SON
OF SITTING VICE PRESIDENT AT
EXORBITANT RATE FOR NO WORK AT
THE VERY MOMENT HIS FATHER WAS
POLICING "ANTICORRUPTION EFFORTS
IN THEIR COUNTRY."
THERE IS NOTHING ABOUT THAT.
IF YOU THINK OTHERWISE, YOU
BELIEVE IN A CONSPIRACY THEORY
COME A DEFUNCT CONSPIRACY THEORY
TO MY THEORY DEBUNKED, IN FACT,
THE PRESIDENT WITH LITERALLY AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE SIMPLY BY
ASKING ABOUT IT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE WASN'T AT
ALL AND ABUSE OF POWER BUT
REALLY THE OPPOSITE OF AN ABUSE
OF POWER?
WHEN THE LAST PRESIDENT
PRESIDENT OBAMA KILLED THE U.S.
CITIZEN, NOT ABUSE OF POWER, ARE
YOU KIDDING?
THAT IS ANOTHER DEBUNKED THEORY
OR WHEN HE HAD THE FBI WITH A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN ON
FRAUDULENT DOSSIER OF RESEARCH
WRITTEN BY A FOREIGNER.
USING INTEL FOR THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT.
THAT WAS NOT AN ABUSE OF POWER,
WHAT?
YOU ARE CRAZY.
FOX NEWS OR SOMETHING, YOU
FREAK.
AND WHILE WE ARE ON THE TOPIC,
BY THE WAY THE LAST SEVERAL
PRESIDENTS BUSH, OBAMA, AND YES,
TRUMP HAVE OVERSEEN THE GROWTH
OF A BRAND-NEW SURVEILLANCE
STATE ONE AIMED AT YOU AND ME
COME AMERICAN CITIZENS.
THAT WAS NOT AN ABUSE OF POWER.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE WATCHED NEW
WARS WITHOUT ASKING CONGRESS IN
VIOLATION OF THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES WHICH REQUIRES
THEM TO DO SO EXPLICITLY, NOT AN
ABUSE OF POWER.
WITH EVERY PASSING NEAR THE
PRESIDENT BECOMES A LOT MORE
LIKE A MONARCHY, NOT AN ABUSE OF
POWER.
IN FACT, NO BIG DEAL, BEST ABOUT
100 BY DENSE SLEAZY DEAL WITH
UKRAINE, THAT IS IT, PAL, WE ARE
REMOVING YOU FROM OFFICE.
THE SECOND ARTICLE OF
IMPEACHMENT BY THE WAY ACCUSES
THE PRESIDENT OF OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS.
THE CRANE HERE SUPPOSEDLY TO
COMPLY WITH CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENAS, SUBPOENAS OF THE ONES
THE PHONE COMPANIES THAT GOT
PEOPLE'S PHONE RECORDS LAST
WEEK.
BUT DUE PROCESS.
IF YOU DON'T LIVE IN WASHINGTON
COME I KNOW THAT NEITHER PARTY
ACTUALLY TAKES THIS SERIOUSLY, B
ACTUALLY TAKES THIS SERIOUSLY, T
ACTUALLY TAKES THIS SERIOUSLY, H
PARTIES KNOW IT'S NOT A
REASON TO IMPEACH.
CLINTON SAID SUBPOENAS
CONSISTENTLY, CONSTANTLY DURING
HIS IMPEACHMENT SAGA 20 YEARS
AGO.
NOBODY REMEMBERS THAT.
NOBODY WOULD CARE SO WE WILL
SPARE A LONG EXPLANATION OF IT,
BUT IT HAPPENED.
COME ON, NONE OF THIS IS ABOUT
HIGH CRIMES OR MISDEMEANORS AND
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO MAKE THAT
CASE.
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
TWO REASONS, FIRST, DEMOCRATS
THEY WERE TWITTER, HAVE NOT
ACCEPTED DEFEAT OF 2016.
THEY THINK IMPEACHMENT WILL
NULLIFY THAT SHOCKING LOSS LIKE
IT NEVER HAPPENED.
AND ALLOW THEM TO IGNORE EVERY
LESSON THAT CAME WITH THAT
ELECTION.
THE LESSON BOTH PARTIES NEEDED
TO LEARN BUT DIDN'T AND HAVE NO
INTEREST IN LEARNING.
THEY CONTINUE TO IGNORE THOSE
BECAUSE TRUMP WAS IMPEACHED.
HE IS AN ANOMALY.
SOME WEIRD ORANGE GUY SHOWED UP
IT FOR A FEW YEARS, BUT WE
KICKED HIM OUT.
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHY VOTERS
SUPPORTED HIM IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
BUT THE OTHER REASON IS LOOKING
TO THE FUTURE.
SOME DEMOCRATS, AND SOME OF THEM
SINCERELY BELIEVE THAT
IMPEACHMENT WILL HELP THEIR CASE
IN THE 2020 ELECTION.
SO THEY UNIFY THEIR BAYS,
DEMORALIZED OPPOSITION OF
REPUBLICANS, HUMILIATE THE
PRESIDENT AND IMPROVE CHANCES OF
WINNING THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
ARE THEY RIGHT ABOUT THAT?
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT AS A TONIGHT
PULLING SUGGEST IT MIGHT NOT
BE THAT SIMPLE.
EVERY THREE MONTHS FIREHOUSE
STRATEGIES IN WASHINGTON PULLING
VOTERS IN WISCONSIN,
PENNSYLVANIA, MICHIGAN AND THE
THREE CRITICAL SWING STATES THAT
MADE TRUMP PRESIDENT IN 2016.
IN ALL THE PREVIOUS POLLS, THIS
YEAR CONDUCTED BY FIREHOUSE, THE
PRESIDENT TRAILED JOE BIDEN IN
EVERY ONE OF THOSE STATES.
BUT THE FIREHOUSE'S MOST RECENT
POLL, TRUMP IS LEADING BY DEN
AND EVERY OTHER DEMOCRAT IN ALL
THREE STATES.
NOW, THE ECONOMY IS OBVIOUSLY
GOING ALONG TO SOME MEASUREMENTS
ANYWAY, AND THAT IS REALLY
HELPING THE PRESIDENT, BUT IT
DOES SEEM LIKE AT THE VERY
MOMENT TRUMP IS BEING IMPEACHED,
HIS NUMBER SHOULD BE GOING DOWN,
AND THEY ARE NOT.
THEY ARE COMING UP.
SO IT IS POSSIBLE INSTEAD OF
SECURING VICTORY IN 2020, THE
IMPEACHMENT EFFORTS COULD BE
LEADING THE DEMOCRATS INTO A
CATASTROPHE.
WHY WOULDN'T THAT BE THE CASE?
IF YOU STRIP AWAY ALL THE
ANALYSIS, HERE'S THE BOTTOM ON
IT, POLLS SHOW CONSISTENTLY FOR
MOST VOTERS WHO ARE NOT ON
TWITTER MOST TIME IMPEACHING THE
PRESIDENT IS NOT CLOSE TO THE
TOP OF THE LIST OF THEIR
PRIORITIES.
THEY CARE ABOUT THE THINGS YOU
WOULD EXPECT THEM TO CARE ABOUT
THE THINGS YOU CARE ABOUT NO
MATTER WHAT PARTY YOU READ IT
INTEREST OR WITH, HERE
HEALTH CARE, STUDENT WAGES,
CRIME, REAL AND RISING, THE
BORDER WHICH IS OPEN, IT'S NOT
EVEN A BORDER ANYMORE, AND EVERY
OTHER ISSUE THAT IS NOT
IMPEACHMENT.
AND THAT SHOULDN'T SURPRISE YOU
BECAUSE THOSE ISSUES ACTUALLY
AFFECT PEOPLE, EVEN MORE, BRACE
YOURSELVES NOW, EVEN MORE THAN
INTERNAL UKRAINIAN POLITICS.
SO EVERY DAY, THE DEMOCRATS
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ALL OF THEIR